you've said I actually read this a
couple days ago
I was reading an article about you and
you said that you were interested in
retiring soon
I would love though you would like to
retire oh that's younger retire what
would you do well I'm not 50 anymore I'm
50 in a couple weeks
yeah sure yeah yeah I think if I I would
like to retire earlier than later
because I think I would like to do zero
now you say you would do nothing but
you'd have to do something so explain to
me what that something would be I mean
you'd have to you know mean you can't
just lie in bed all day and have ice
cream put in your veins intravenously
you'd have to get up wait a minute and
then maybe you could I don't know what
would you want to do let's get any
typical day would like sleep as long as
you want or get up early if you want
yeah it's just not having to go
somewhere or someone else telling you
what you have to do and then maybe go to
the gym or not go to the gym maybe have
nine cups of coffee coffee or none right
I mean it's kind of given this a lot of
thought get up and go drive the
bulldozer around all day that's right
you have a we talked about this even
Ranchi just drive a bulldozer around we
just drive it all day room yeah all do
oh yeah maybe I get another one we could
race him I could come over and we could
raise something but you'd have to be at
work what do you mean hey you could come
by here like every day he could sit in
with us Andy every single day wouldn't
you like that
right right right right he said you're a
fun guy and that would be your gig we'd
pay you something wouldn't be what
you're accustomed to but you'd get
something it would be like more than an
intern but less than a producer you know
what you should do is announce your
retirement right here on the air and
then just start showing up every night
you should just retire right now right
now yeah I quit yeah audience that went
ah when you announced you might retire
when you announced your retirement
cheered wildly loyal to me
you